good to have you on the program thank
you for your time so what exactly does
the brexit party stand for well of
course it stands for democracy it stands
for the re-establishment of trust
between people and the politicians of
course we want the referendum
implemented as it was promised but
actually we're about more than that
we're about fundamental change in
British politics we think there needs to
be a genuine political revolution in
this country the two-party system isn't
working it's not fit for purpose
Parliament now simply does not reflect
the mood and the will of the people in
this country so for us the European
elections on May the 23rd are the first
step towards completely trying to reform
British politics okay so does that mean
you have a manifesto written you have
policies in place on the likes of income
tax and education oh all of that Stu
come it's a very new party and we're
going to fight a European election on
those issues of democracy trust and
indeed competence because one of the
things that I'm quite proud to say is
the brexit party is putting forward
people who have had some serious success
in business life the sort of people who
know how to do a deal and I think isn't
just a feeling that we've been betrayed
by Parliament but there's a feeling
there's almost no one competent running
the show and we're gonna put a very
different face on politics in that way
so competence what about diversity
what's the percentage number of your
candidates who have been fielded from
ethnic minority backgrounds well I don't
know whether you saw the platform today
and you saw our launch but I think
you'll find a much higher percentage
than the other parties what is that then
give me a number I mean how many
building well I've only I've only
revealed to count of four candidates so
far two of whom came from ethnically
diverse backgrounds that's 50% doesn't
mean the oldest will be and come on we
shouldn't be thinking actually too much
about quotas and numbers which were
thinking about ability and that's what
we'll do and you're going to see a very
considerable cross-section of this
country standing for the requisite party
okay now you're going to try and
convince that the electorate that you
are different from UK it's similar in
policy but different in personnel yes
similar on Europe yes okay
but crucially personnel because of the
problem different personnel but but I
just thought we're going in the points
that regarding your former brexit party
leader she's already had to resign or
comments that she made on Twitter very
Islamophobic comments I mean this isn't
the best of starts is it we had a couple
of teething problems and let me tell you
something we are seeing arm two being
submissive we are going to be we're
going to be as a party deeply intolerant
of intolerance you know we're not the
Labour Party we're not going to turn a
blind eye to anti-semitism or any any of
those things we in the brexit party will
not have it all right so how confident
are you that the views of Miss Blakelock
are not widely held within the brexit
party we will not be having it all right
it's as simple as that
those views aren't widely held this is
just the beginning well you wait and see
you wait and see the list of 70 people
that we put before the British public
I've got a feeling there'll be the most
impressive list of candidates you've
ever seen from any UK political party
talking about a list of candidates so
impressive in candidates we were
surprised to see uh Nancy artery smoke
on the podium with you were you well
look this issue this issue is leaving
people in all of our parties feeling
absolutely let down cheated and betrayed
by what's going on so so what does she
bring to your party
well she's highly intelligent she
probably knows more about the European
subject and virtually anybody else maybe
apart from her brother and Bill cash
she knows the subject inside out she's
very very passionate and she believes
we've got to do something to save our
democracy to restore trust and faith
between the governors and the governed
and all say what about our standing in
the world
you know we're becoming an international
laughingstock and she wants to do
something about that could this be the
beginning of maybe more members from the
ERG coming over what about Jacob
well no he's made it very clear that his
loyalty to the Conservative Party is
very strong and that's his own decision
but I just think look I these these
existing political parties they can't
cope with brexit it's not working and we
are looking to change and realign
politics in this country there is a
danger but by doing this and standing in
the European elections against a Tory
party that you are going to be taking
valuable votes away from them is that
what you're intending to do well we may
take valuable votes away from the Labour
Party don't forget that in 2015 the only
reason David Cameron got a majority is
because of the four million votes that
you keep took it took more from labour
that it took from the Conservatives you
know this question about being a
democratic country is not a left or
right wing ask you well some people say
you're doing Jeremy Corbyn a favor here
the old two-party system doesn't work
it's fail we've got to move on we need
some new politics here okay and where's
our funding coming from well that's the
remarkable thing and I think so far the
most pleasing thing is that ten days
after our website went live we've
managed to raise over three-quarters of
a million pounds in small donations the
biggest being 150 pounds and that shows
you there's an appetite out there in the
country for something different it's a
fantastic start these are not just
backers by rich billionaires here well
at the moment we're being funded by
ordinary people giving us 10 quid 20
quid and up to and including 150 quid
and it's a very very heartening thing to
see you're putting a huge amount of
effort into the elections there is a
possibility that these in the elections
never come for Britain how confident are
you that we will get to May the 23rd
you can't start an election and call it
off midway through I mean people have
been cheated of one vote already to
cheat them of another one would be an
outrage but but there is a chance isn't
there but the withdrawal deal will make
it through Parliament before this
election date are you what do you think
about that could that happen I just
don't think I just do not believe that
Parliament is going to vote for this
appalling new treaty I just don't
believe it now and are you preparing for
a second referendum are you ready to
fight that
well we shouldn't have a second
referendum until until we've implemented
the first one so if there is a second
referendum in a few years time then yeah
we'll be ready for it there's no need to
have one now all we need to do is to
deliver people were promised explicitly
that if they voted for brexit in the
referendum that it would be implemented
and that's not happening and that is an
absolute failure of leadership and a
breakdown of trust and democracy in our
country and the general election are you
ready for that we're preparing for it
we're not ready for it we're only a
couple of weeks old you know we've done
an awful lot in a short space of time
but look 23rd of May for us is the
beginning of our political journey and
just very briefly mr. frost is it time
for treason later stand down well it was
time for her to stand down a long time
ago but I guess she'll stay on and and I
have to say I think she's the worst
leader I've seen in my lifetime I was at
the summit the other evening it was
pretty humiliating even being a British
person in attendance well leave it there
Nigel Faraj thank you very you